welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3
is now on digital and I was able to find
so many more Easter eggs and clues and
details that I missed the first time
around you may have noticed we always
try to cover our bases with these re
breakdowns we did this with quantumania
the Incredible Hulk in the past month
and now with new info like James Gunn
confirming that the high evolutionary
survived the events in the film we just
thought it'd be a good idea to go back
and revisit it and all its
heartbreakingly cute enhanced animal
Glory let's do this now I did some
in-depth analysis of volume 1 and volume
2 on the Deep dive Channel check those
out and hit that subscribe button please
and thank you okay this film opens with
a Guardians of the Galaxy themed version
of the Marvel Studios title card with
moments from across there prior seven
appearances in the MCU we see famous
script lines from the Guardians history
including Peter Quill's Showtime a-holes
quills some unspoken thing from volume 1
draxxas there are two types of people in
the universe those who dance and those
who do not Rockets a bunch of jackasses
standing in a circle from volume one
groots we are Groot Rockets ain't
nothing like me set me which is really
the perfect quote to set up the rocket
Centric movie we're about to watch
speaking of Rocket and Groot James Gunn
posted some unused info on their
backstories into his threads account
linking back to tibias Lark tibia Lark
was listed as an associate of Rocket and
Groot during the mug shot scene in
volume 1. he's not a Marvel Comics
character but rather an invasion of
James Gunn Gunn intended to pay this off
with a short film for this movie that
was storyboarded but never shot in the
script Lark was a Space Zookeeper who
saved Groot from his Zoo but wound up
getting them both thrown in prison with
rocket tibias would die and reveal that
he was a robot rocket would then make a
machine gun out of tibius's body and
escape with Groot setting up why rocket
always wants people's body parts and can
quick fashion weapons out of anything
okay moving on the first image in yellow
on the Marvel text is rocket crying from
the final shot of volume 2. this movie
is Rocket's heartbreaking story of his
unique quality the last thing we see
before the images wipe away is the
guardian's first team up shot in the
Kiln in volume one reminding us how this
all started we get the beginning and
this film is going to show us the end of
of this team as we know it so we fade in
on a cage of scurrying baby raccoons
designed by VFX company frame store and
they are so sweet so adorable their
playfulness turns to Terror as a high
evolutionary slowly walks toward the
cage James Gunn stated that this is not
Herbert Wyndham from the comics since
Wyndham was from Earth this character is
an alien from another planet here he
remains out of focus with the cage
itself in the foreground allowing the
viewer to experience what the kits are
experiencing their ears fold down in
fear as all of them except for one turn
their backs and attempt to hide only
eight nine p13 stays front and center
that sets up right away that there is
something different about rocket the
high evolutionary reaches into the cage
with his palm facing down which is a
threatening gesture that's known to
trigger animals so they suggest Palm up
and then we get this cool effect where
we push in on Rocket's nose in the fur
warps into adult rocket because he has a
different skull shape that was
physically Changed by the surgeries so
we transitioned to present day rocket on
nowhere where we saw in the holidays
special the Guardians have settled on as
their new home along with some refugees
although we should know while nowhere is
taken in refugees it seems like they
didn't take in any Scrolls who is
established in secret evasion are still
on the hunt for a permanent home whether
that's because of xenophobia towards
skulls or the Scrolls never really
considering nowhere for some other
reason we don't know maybe some of the
people walking around this planet are
Scrolls in Disguise rocket sings along
to an acoustic version of radiohead's
creep on the Zune that originally
belonged to yondu but was passed on to
Peter by cragland after yondu's death in
volume 2. notice how we see rocket
turning up the music and the amplifiers
behind to begin pulsing intensely it
just makes perfect sense that rocket is
an outcast who hates himself for what
the high evolutionary turned him into
would respond to this song and he wants
everyone to know where to hear his cry
for help it reminds us how he and Groot
rigged up the awesome mix Vol 2 to play
from speakers in the opening sequence of
the second film James Gunn always writes
his track list into the scripts and he
plays the music on set to inspire the
actors he justifies the music Source in
the context of the scene to make it
diegetic so the songs aren't just
randomly playing over everything but
really a choice a character made to play
this song gonna said that he feels like
rocket has always been a secret
protagonist to these films and quote one
of the reasons why I came back to make
this movie was because I felt like I
needed to tell Rocket's story I think he
exemplifies a lot of the traits of all
the Guardians they all had these traumas
and it brings them together I just think
his is more extreme than others so this
movie really is the story of rockets
trauma the Guardians aren't trying to
save the entire galaxy they're really
just trying to save rocket and this
movie explains why he needs saving it's
truly one of the most character focused
MCU films to date by Saving one member
of the Guardians of the Galaxy they end
up stating everything as Rocket moves
through nowhere we see a few people
dancing and one of these is mantis who
tries to attracts to dance but he says
holy idiots dance this is an ongoing
thing with Drax since he said in volume
2. there are two types of beings in the
universe those who dance and those who
do not lead into my long-running MCU
theory that all Marvel characters are
depicted as either dancers or
non-dancers nebula and swole group raise
a neon sign written in the cree language
it translates to Guardians of the Galaxy
and we see that underneath it this Groot
has a different Anatomy than volume 1
groots adult form because that group was
really his father it's not his clone and
we have now seen Groot as a dancing baby
a Troublesome little kid and a moody
team now he's in his college jock stage
of development Groot is the floor
Colossus and they feed on photonic
knowledge gained from light sources
since Groot has been the company of
beings like quill and mantis descended
from a Celestial I have theorized that
he could have absorbed their Celestial
light and grown more that way now no
word as of yet if any of that Celestial
light could have made it into the DNA
source of Groot that the squirrels found
and used in secret evasion nebula you'll
notice as a new nanotech weave arm which
James Gunn confirmed was made for her by
rocket to thank her for gifting him
Bucky's detached vibranium arm in the
holiday special which by the way we
still have no idea how she got I really
don't think we're gonna get an answer to
that one folks rocket walks into the
Nowhere bar where drunk Peter is still
moping over Gamora rocket sips a drink
from a container marked in Cree letters
translating to milky Fizz they actually
had this drink available to buy in
Disneyland on Avengers campus we get a
classic Guardians walking toward the
camera in slow motion with a cool song
playing shot this reminds us what the
guardian status quo is with craglin
wielding the yondu Mohawk Groot as the
swole young adult Cosmo Rolanda at the
group and Peter drunken depressed thanks
to the loss of his Dimensions Gamora and
infinity War and the fact that the cool
song in question is a downbeat grunge
classic as opposed to a late 70s AM
radio Banger that they usually use it's
just tipping this off that this is going
to be a bit darker than the other
Guardians movies nebula turns out
Peter's bedroom light as written and
directed by James Gunn pops up on screen
showing that he's really putting his
Trilogy to bed here now nowhere is
established with new coordinates m211
r516xs different than the volume 1
coordinates which were m3rd 17 H17 211
plus two one two one two two four the
fact that nowhere has different
coordinates sets up the Twist and the
third Act of the planet is in fact a
mobile battle station able to be piloted
as scraggling gets ready to practice his
yaka Arrow skills we see that he's done
this before as one guy says here we go
this actor is Stephen blakehart standard
in James Gunn movies he played the same
character in volume 1 and in the holiday
special and he was brawl and volume 2.
he was also in the suicide squad and
Peacemaker a bunch of other James Gunn
stuff Cosmo is voiced by Maria bakalova
and supporting a spacesuit with the cccp
logo which stands for Central Committee
of the Communist party as she is based
on Leica this poor space dog that was
sent into space without any plan to
bring that poor dog back the group
discusses Peter's emotional state while
snacking on roasted or loaning which pop
up all over the Guardians movies we
first saw one of these in the opening of
volume one when Peter kicked it during
his lip-syncing performance so now Adam
warlock's speeds toward nowhere to the
tune of Hearts Crazy on You his cape
flapping in the space wind capes are
used in the MCU really to symbolize big
egos Kurt Russell who plays a character
literally named ego Sports One Loki has
a cape in his first two appearances Thor
wears one but ditches it in later movies
as it becomes more of a team player
Vision synthesizes himself a cape and
Age of Ultron after giving Thor a little
side eye so Adam Warlock really fits
into this tradition nicely the high
evolutionary will go on to say about
Adam's people your egos have run wild
the bolt in Adam's head is a nod to the
comics iteration carrying the soul gem
in his forehead he plays a major role in
The Infinity Gauntlet storyline but the
MC really assigned that detail to Vision
with the Mind Stone but gun leaves in a
little reminder of his Origins here
after warlock tackles rocket to the
ground we see some neon lettering and
Cree translating to you and K nebula
uses her new arm Tech to blast warlock
earning her a dislocated jaw as he
tosses her aside like a rag doll even
swole group doesn't stand a chance
against him group gets beheaded but
later Sprouts Branch legs out of his
head looking like the spider head form
of the shape-shifter from John Carpenter
is the thing which was starring Peter
Quill's dad ego Kurt Russell Adam
Warlock also snaps mantis's arm like a
pretzel stick and it Drax gives him the
same treatment that he just gave nebula
tossing him into the newly erected
Guardian sign and splitting into half be
able uses their other feature on her new
arm to stab him through the chest from
the back much like we saw Loki due to
Coulson and Avengers a mortally wounded
rocket flashes back to one of his
enhancements at the hands of the high
evolutionary here we meet Lila tiefs and
floor in a scene that I think is
reminiscent of the moment in the first
Toy Story when Sid's broken toys come
out first frightening Buzz and Woody
before it's revealed that they're just
trying to help now Lila an honor
creature is voiced by Linda Cardellini
who also plays Laura Barton in the MCU
thiefs The Walrus is voiced by yasim
Chaudhry and Flora the rabbit is voiced
by Michaela Hoover who also played Nova
Prime's assistant in the first Guardians
film little Rocket's first spoken word
is
and it's just so heartbreaking now
recently James Gunn shared some sketches
containing new details about Lila
florentips said their numbers are
respectively eight nine q and two eight
nine J 5-0 which is changed to 89l06 and
for thieves eight nine a95 along with
rocket who is 89 p13 they were part of
batch 89. we also see that originally
the idea for floor is that every time
she talked her mouth was going to scrape
and cut herself which is just so mean as
Lila tells her rocket you're going to be
okay we cut to the guardian standing
around him because they're really the
ones who made him okay the high
evolutionary installed a kill switch and
Rocket considering his Parts proprietary
technology Groot has now reformed
himself a bit so he's able to stand
again you'll notice we get a sense of
the guardian's new ship the Bowie which
is named after David Bowie and following
the pattern of naming ships after people
who were famous when Peter was young
like we saw the Milano in volume 1 and
volume 2 named after Alyssa Milano the
Benatar Infinity war end game named
after Pat Benatar we hear rainbows since
you've been gone playing on their way to
orga Corp we see orete Laboratories a
mobile research complex on counter Earth
coordinates k20h
mw1748 p2s plus
5m5p0z4 Aisha Comforts Adam who says
echoing little Rocket's first word hurts
and letting us know that Adam is still
very much a little kid despite having
the adult body of Will Poulter and we
get our first look at the present day
high evolutionary whose face is now
stretched out and pulled over a metallic
clip at his Temple so we know something
has happened to him in the time since
the flashbacks we've seen the face we
see is really another layer of wallpaper
over whatever is underneath in the
comics the high evolutionary is Marvel's
Ultimate geneticist from Thor comics in
1966 who played a role in the 2008
Annihilation Conquest storyline that
these Guardians films are partially
based on now again this character isn't
that high evolutionary because that one
was Herbert Windham but he was also
known for creating the animal human
hybrids the anime and the new men here
he's played by chiquity Ouija who of
course James Gunn worked with on
Peacemaker the Guardians arrived at the
orgoscope at Oregon Corp HQ coordinates
a41p
p2326y for 30 plus
174144v this is the evolutionary's
corporate front for the cybernetic parts
and implants used around the Galaxy
remember yondu new scientists made
rocket which tells us that the Galaxy
must know the evolutionary is and all
about his experiments just kind of looks
the other way Drax is eating zargnuts
and offers one to Peter but doesn't
offer any domantas who glares at him
just love these little background
details this is a call back to Holiday
Special where Drax brings up her eating
all the zark nuts in the commissary he's
still holding The Grudge Peters wearing
a red shirt with another orloni on it
maybe a shirt from the roasted orlony
stand that we saw earlier and he says
people on Earth die when they're like
50. are you about to die
but closely attracts when
because if Peter's about to die drags
nods it's just another really fun
background detail the Guardians are
boarded by The ravagers Who alternate
timeline Gamora from Avengers end game
has joined she and nebula give each
other a grunty nod this is really how
the sisters communicate throughout the
movie and now that we have the ability
to pause at will we will try to identify
everyone in the scene so we got
stacarogord played by Sly Stallone the
robot Mainframe who's still looking very
Cyberman from Doctor who-esque voiced by
Miley Cyrus in the Guardians 2 post
credit scene but here voiced by Tara
Strong the voice of Miss minutes and
Loki and Raven in Teen Titans Go also
returning from the Guardians Volume 2
post credit scene we have martinex the
humanoid made of crystals played by
Michael Rosenbaum and Krueger who is
wielding some Doctor Strange sling rings
in the comics he's actually sorcerer's
Supreme from Earth 691 an alternate 31st
Century reality his ravager badge on his
chest has a green gem on it which he
might use as his own eye of agamoto it
wouldn't be a time Stone since the time
Stone was atomized in this universe now
miss scene from the Guardians 2 post
credit scene are Michelle Yos Elita and
Ving Rhames charlie27 these next votes
are listed on IMDb but their names
aren't said aloud we have Fitz gibbenok
ravager Molly and then behind her we
have BD ravager who is the one with the
beard then there's the blue guy who
might be a luffamoid which is nebula's
race then we got this creepy guy who
might be from the same Planet as the
broker because they seem to have some
similar features there's a couple
humanoid looking dudes who are just
frankly too well quick to be space
pirates if you ask me you know who they
are or what planet they're from let me
know in the comments okay the orgo Corp
jumpsuits that the Guardians change into
have a logo that looks like a flayed man
just evoking out rocket looked during
his operation rocket flashes back to
another memory with a high evolutionary
and now that he's a little bit older
rocket is once again voiced by Bradley
Cooper the transformation of the Turtle
test subject into a tube filled with
smoke just might remind you of the
transformation scene in The Incredible
Hulk where Bruce Banner is trapped in
the glass room as it's filled with tear
gas before he hulks out the test subject
here turns into a similar green monster
with an anger problem it also reminds me
a lot of Terror Genesis in which the
terrigen Mist is inhaled and causes the
creature to mutate into a super powered
inhuman we saw Terror Genesis with the
Inhumans TV show also Agents of Shield
space hogs in the meantime plays as the
Guardians float down toward the Orca
Corp in the colorful spacesuits which
James Gunn said in a tweet are supposed
to invoke the spacesuits from 2001 A
Space Odyssey this is a planet made of
living matter it may remind fans of ego
The Living Planet with some tendon-like
structures holding it together looking
like the ones inside ego in the
Guardians 2 final battle nebula wears
the green suit Gamora wears the blue one
showing us how they've really traded
roles in the Guardians group since we
were first introduced to the two of them
nebula's arm cane it looks like it's
made from the same Tech as a destroyer
from the first Thor movie Destroyer
Attack has popped up a lot in the MCU
including the gun that Coulson threatens
Loki with before the shank that may or
may not have been fatal depending on
whether or not he consider agency Shield
to be Cannon we've all got a certain
amount of chores we've got to do and we
want them all to be as easy as possible
right that's why we swapped out brooms
for vacuums for roombas and it's the
same reason you should try clean my Mac
X clean my Mac X is a one-click solution
to get your Mac running like new think
about it what would you rather do spend
hours of time going through system files
manually clearing the cache finding junk
or recovering infected files or just
click the smart scan and have clean my
Mac X do all that for you smart scan
handles cleanup protection and system
performance with one click of a button
in just a few minutes it's why Apple you
know the people who make Macs say we
love how easy it is and also why
cleanmymacx has over 27 million
satisfied users clean my Mac X is one
app for complete Mac care start your
seven day free trial by clicking the
link in the description below or use
promo code new rockstars to get 25 off
your order to get your Mac running like
new today we say frequent James gun
player Nathan Fillion playing master
karja in an outfit that makes him look
like a big tardigrade if you ask me
billion cameo in volume one it's blue
skinned alien in the Kiln and came out
in a deleted scene for volume 2 playing
Wonder Man Simon Williams the movie
posters and he has just been cast as
Lantern Guy Gardner and James Gunn's
upcoming Superman Legacy and speaking of
James Gunn's regulars tons of them pop
up in this movie we already talked about
Sylvester Stallone who also provides the
voice of king shark in the suicide squad
the orgo Corp security head and minister
quall is a cameo by Jennifer Holland
James Gunn's wife who also appeared
Peacemaker and a Black Adam the orgo
Corp worker they've forced to help them
is Ura played by Daniella melchior who
played rat catcher 2 in The Suicide
Squad and yeah we know Sean gun he plays
craglin obviously James Gunn's brother
also played weasel and calendar man in
Suicide Squad Gerardo davalia who plays
ravager of hits gibbenok also popped up
in the suicide squad as general Vera D
Bradley Baker who does the voice of
blurp also provides animal voices for
The Suicide Squad and Peacemaker he was
once a voice of eagerly remember
Peacemaker and then Ronaldo fabarale who
does the voice of Behemoth also in the
suicide squad as one of the Guerrilla
Fighters Lloyd Kaufman the founder of
troma Studios or James gun got his start
appears in both the first Guardians of
the Galaxy movies as a prisoner and in
this one as griddle mop there's also
deleted scene with Pete Davidson who had
a very memorable death in The Suicide
Squad just James Gunn loves doing stuff
like this and he said that one or more
Guardians can make their way into his
DCU movies he specifically said that
he's been talking to Palm Clementi about
an unspecified role if there's any other
gun regulars we missed let us know in
the comments Peter tosses the 89p13
sphere like a baseball just like he did
with the orb in the 2014 film remember
he accidentally dropped it in that shot
and they kept that take in so Groot gets
ready to Pilot the ship and we hear
Earth Wind and fires reasons
[Music]
we heard their song shining star in both
Doctor Strange as well as the Daredevil
Netflix series Peter turns off the
gravity for the Soldier's suits a
version of the sun rocket polls in the
first Guardians of the Galaxy movie to
get them out of Kiln prison this shows
that the Guardians have really been
learning from each other's playbooks
Gamora says that the high evolutionary
created zoronians any men and The
Sovereign Remember The Sovereign are
Aisha's people which explains why we
never really knew what the Sovereign
were or where they came from any men are
the animal human hybrids and there are a
few different iterations of them in the
comics but in one they included the
likes of Frogman and apeman and then
zeronians are the pale skin humanoids
with plates that cover their mouths we
saw some of them with the collector and
Thor of the dark world's post-credits
scene and in the background of all the
Guardians the Galaxy titles in the
comics as aronians are really peaceful
race who can gain powers from solar
radiation So Adam Warlock adopts blurp
the furry fasaki sidekick the ravager he
accidentally fried now furry fasaki are
carnivorous creatures about the size of
the cat and there was also a reptilian
version that we saw in the fighting pit
and the first Guardians of the Galaxy
movie on nowhere feeding on orlonies
Peter listens to The Flaming Lips do you
realize on his Zune and we hear the line
we're floating in space as they actually
are floating in space Faith No More is
We Care a Lot plays as the Guardians
arrive on counter Earth cornett's k-20h
mw1748p2s plus five and five P zero Z4
we see a dupe of the Statue of Liberty
but with the high evolutionary holding
the monkey which is definitely
reminiscent at the end of the 2001
Planet of the Apes movie by Tim Burton
with his Lincoln Memorial is an ape this
baby in the stroller also has a high
evolutionary doll it's clinging to
showing that to them the high
evolutionary is likely a benevolent
figure instead of the monster we know
him to be and he's about to prove to all
them he is the fashion in Tech on
counter Earth suggests that they're
culturally stuck somewhere in the late
70s or early 80s which would have been
around the time when Peter Quill left
Earth this is never explained but we can
assume that counter Earth was created
fairly recently and its inhabitants
wouldn't be caught up to those of
standard Earth yet but among these
period details are this retro jogging
suit and this tiny skateboard inside the
counter Earth home we hear a song called
koinu No Carnival from only minute Walls
by ehamek
so this is produced by Vocaloid which is
a voice synthesizer software with over
15 Vocaloid creators represented here
including what sounds like Cosmo howling
The house's many 80s flourishes as well
like the alien kids play with retro
looking toys there's no alien Roblox in
sight though the family seems to have
gotten their photo taken at some kind of
counter Earth version of the Sears
Portrait Studio there's a school
portrait of one of the kids that has
those neon lasers in the background that
anyone who went to school during a
certain era remembers and of course
there's this very 70s looking car that
Peter commandeers there's also some
adorable animal themed wallpaper that's
all over the walls literally every
detail in this home is awesome and
speaking of the car it is the reason for
the mcu's first server F-bomb PG-13
movie like this is allowed to have just
one in an interview James Gunn said it
wasn't scripted but something he
suggested to Chris Pratt in the moment
now Deadpool has of course used multiple
f-bombs with those first two movies were
in the fox Marvel Universe and they were
rated R this is the MCU the upcoming
Deadpool 3 though will be part of the
MCU and rated R so we can assume this
movie's most f-bombs in an MCU record is
gonna be broken and then some Peter
hands screwed its blasters and says you
know what to do with these this will pay
off later in the shootout in the high
evolutionaries base as Peter tries to
drive the car the streets sign
cautioning drivers about pedestrians as
animal heads instead of human heads we
hear Alice Coopers I'm always chasing
rainbows as Gamora checks out some of
Peter's keepsakes from his childhood on
Earth we see some Garbage Pail Kids
cards an action figure of Panther from
the ThunderCats a report card with c's
and D's in every subject except PE where
you gotta be and some ALF trading cards
remember Alf Comics are technically
Marvel and one of those Comics showed up
in I am Groot in this backpack as well
Peter nebula and Groot drive through the
slums of counter Earth and we see a drug
deal going down the dealer is played by
Dane Robert de legro a basketball player
to an actor who played the predator in
prey test subjects phyla runs in a ring
around the high evolutionary like the
jogging sequence in 2001 A Space Odyssey
phyla is played by Kaizen and returns
with post credit scene she's the MCU
version of phylavel who becomes Quasar
in the annihilation Conquest storyline
to artificially created daughter of the
cree Marvel and companion to drax's
daughter moon dragon based on her
glowing eye in the post-credit scene it
looks like her powers have the same Cree
Cosmic radiation source as Monica Rambo
Kamala Khan and Carol Danvers and based
on the latest trailer for the Marvel may
be part of a new super team called the
annihilators Peter and the others meet
two Mutant bruisers named Behemoth and
War Pig who reminded me of Bebop and
Rocksteady from Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles Behemoth like I mentioned
earlier his voice by Reynaldo favarle
from The Suicide Squad War pig is
hilariously voiced by the amazing
character actor Judy Greer who made her
MCU debut as Maggie Scott's ex-wife and
Ant-Man other actors who have played two
characters in the MCU one live action
and one voice over include Linda
Cardellini who plays Lila and Laura
Barton Clancy Brown who played Ray
schoonover and Daredevil and Searcher
and Thor Ragnarok Benedict Cumberbatch
she was both doctor strange and or Mamu
in the same movie and Chris Hemsworth of
course plays Thor in one of hajo's three
heads in Thor Ragnarok and we should
also mention taekwon tisu plays one of
the other three heads who also does Korg
now the way the high evolutionary's
purple suit lights up here looks an
awful lot like the Scarlet Centurion
version of Kang from the quantumania
post credit sequence which just makes me
wonder if these two might have crossed
paths at any point on their super
villain Journeys after seeing different
versions of the afterlife in the MCU
including the ancestral plane of the
Black Panther mythology the duot and the
Moon Knight Valhalla and Thor 11 Thunder
and the soul whole realm of infinity War
we get another depiction here when
rocket sees Lila again in limbo when
rocket wakes up it's a beautiful moment
that I did a whole video diving deep
into I highly recommend you watch that
so when rocket wakes up Peter and Groot
hug him and Groot sneaks in more of his
branches so that he can tug him in even
closer now on nowhere Cosmo plays cards
with craglin Howard the Duck voiced
Again by Seth Green and Lloyd Kaufman
who played the prisoner on the Kiln in
volume one and we see the xandar
Antiquities dealer from volume one
played by Christopher Fairbank with a
great role on Andor and shared the
screen for this iconic moment in Batman
what are you
I'm Batman Peter plays the those this is
the day as he Pilots the Bowie and just
like he did with creep rocket sings
along Drax mantis and nebula run into
some abolisks one of the creatures we
saw in volume 2 which fed on any lack's
batteries a fact that mantis reminds the
group of here as she tames them Peter
plays The Beastie Boys No Sleep till
Brooklyn which is also referenced to
Spider-Man no way home
No Sleep Till
Boston Intergalactic was also been
playing in trailers for the Marvels
[Music]
No Sleep till Brooklyn is also featured
in another Chris Pratt movie that came
out this year the Super Mario Brothers
movie come on let's go
this way just kind of having a moment
then we get a full two minute long
unbroken fight take in this hallway
similar to what Daredevil does and it's
pretty cool there's a ton of cool
details during this battle if you look
closely like the camera stays on groot's
branches as he extends them and
punctures the hell spawn one of those
branches goes down to this throat and
grows more to poke through his body I
actually had a chance to sit down with
two of the frame store VFX artists who
worked on this film Alexia and Stefan
and Stefan explain how groot's branches
aren't stretching elastically because
then they would have started to look
like snakes of the mind of their own
instead they were unfurling pieces of
himself they were always folded up and
tucked inside of his chest and therefore
they're more rigid making them feel like
extensions of Groot himself and would
have more impact when they hit stuff be
sure to check out that interview because
there's just so much cool stuff that I
talked to those guys about mantis uses
one of groot's branches like a balance
beam swinging from it and landing on the
guy's shoulders then flipping them
backward into that same branch and you
can actually hear the guard's bones
break
then Rockets shoot the hell spawn lands
on Groot shoulders calling back that
Kiln moment where they teamed up in the
2014 film then runs along a branch and
then the camera swoops through through
the holy just shot Peter fights his way
down the hallway and meets in the Middle
with nebula Peter disabled three guards
nebula gets her neck dislocated and her
head just dangles from her back as she
continues to fight Gamora uses her God
Slayer sword to sever the octopus
captain in half and blurp happily hops
on his sparking and spurting midsection
stump mantis freeze lamb shank this
freaky little hybrid ah thank you yes
you're welcome now lampshank is voiced
by James Gunn who also hilariously did
the bow cap for the character gun said
that he originally wrote this character
for Stan Lee to play since this movie
was actually written before Stan Lee
passed away Rocket returns to his own
cage chamber and on the door the label
reads lumbus Wildlife Center maybe
Columbus Wildlife Center ter
3211-900021 origin North America kingdom
Animalia phylum Cordata that refers to
animals with backbones genus procyon
species procyon LaTour common name
raccoon we actually heard this Genius of
species name spoken by David Hasselhoff
in the Guardians Volume 2 song that
played during that movie's credits and
there's an awesome music video where he
says it getting down and dirty with a
procyon loader so all the Guardians of
the Galaxy team up to fight the high
evolutionary and Gamora peels back his
skin making them look very red Scully if
you ask me paying off Peter Quill's
promise that this was going to be a face
off the test animals all flock Off the
Strip onto nowhere Noah's Ark style and
Alexi from frame store pointed out a few
other details that they threw into the
scene if you look closely you can see a
monkey on top of a taper some turtles on
top of another taper just animals on top
of animals everywhere Peter runs back
for his drop soon in volume 1 he refused
to leave the Kiln without his Walkman a
mixtape Peter jumps out of the exploding
ship into space A lot of people are
asking why doesn't Peter Quill use his
mask in this movie I made a whole other
video getting into that really a lot of
people forget that the mask was
destroyed and guardians of galaxy Vol 2.
despite the fact that the Russo brothers
and infinity war and end game gave Peter
quilla's mask again but in James Gunn's
canonical history Peter doesn't carry
his mask with him and I think James Gunn
has tweeted that Peter Quill left the
mask in his drawer or nowhere and Adam
Warlock rescues him recreating
Michelangelo's creation of Adam and
saves Peter by flying and back into
nowhere another thing in the VFX on this
escape from nowhere you definitely can
see Drax carrying the high evolutionary
on his shoulder the high evolutionary
does survive this so there's an
interesting moment where Gamora
understands group and it's just
surprised as the audience is and it's so
sweet like a more in just a short amount
of time has been able to understand
groot's vocal variances James Gunna said
that Groot doesn't have a universal
language translator but you do come to
understand its language through enough
time connecting with him this explains
why Brockett is the only one who can
understand him in the first movie
yeah you said that but the other
Guardians can once they've started to
act like a team hey
this version of Gamora is gradually
warming the Guardians and understanding
Groot shows that she's making progress
we the audience have been on an
incredible journey with these characters
so it just makes sense that we can
finally understand Groot when he says I
love you guys we are part of the team
even though if you look closely group
doesn't Mount the words I am Groot he
really does vocalize I love you guys but
you know our empathy with him just
causes our eyes to see his lips form the
words that we hear so the group
discusses going their separate ways and
they're standing in the circle a bunch
of jackasses standing in a circle all
the standing except rocket so Peter
leaves rock at the zoo with a note
written on one of the elf trading cards
that we saw earlier in the movie He
plays Florence and the Machines the Dog
Days Are Over Florence Welch the band's
lead singer posted a video to tick tock
saying she cried throughout the movie
but really lost it when her song came on
same floor and same the song itself is
very appropriate for this moment Welch
has said that it's about embracing
things he used to be scared of like
looking in the mirror and not feeling
sad this is a perfect summation of what
rocket learns in this movie to love
himself despite his past it's very
fitting that he starts the movie
listening to song with lyrics I'm a
creep I'm a weirdo and in the movie
listening to this hopeful uplifting
track one of the quotes in the Marvel
logo at the beginning of the film was
Drax explaining that he's not a being
who dances but here he gives in and gets
down I'm so proud of him look how far
he's Come Peter returns to Missouri his
grandfather played once again by Greg
Henry who played him in the 2014 film
and in a cameo in volume 2. now in the
mid credits scene we get the new
Guardians of the Galaxy lineup including
rocket Alpha Groot with a king Groot
crowned head craglin Cosmo blurp Adam
Warlock and Phila Vel rocket plays a new
team redbones come and get your love
which appeared in the opening scene of
the first movie and then in the
post-credits scene Peter wears the
t-shirt for freaky cereal this is a
breakfast cereal from the 70s with Goofy
cartoon mascots it also had a
short-lived relaunch in 1986 where the
mascots were depicted as aliens Peter's
grandfather reads a paper with the
headline alien abduction Kevin Bacon
shares all a reference to the plot of
the Guardians holiday special there's
also a shout out on there to James
Gunn's dog Lola and we end on the text
the legendary star Lord will return
James Gunn said in an interview quote
Chris and I forever have talked about
how great it would be to be able to do a
legendary Star-Lord movie a story with
Star-Lord on Earth trying to adapt to
the environment of Earth in the same way
that somebody else might try to adapt to
the alien environment of outer space
he's a fish out of water and just kind
of regular water so I can't wait to see
it legendary Star-Lord is a 12 issue
comic series that deals with Peter Quill
leaving the Guardians for a solo
Adventure the Peter in the comics is a
very different backstory in the Peter
and the MCU so we probably wouldn't be
seeing a note for note adaptation in
that series but rather another Star-Lord
solo adventure and yes again James Gunn
confirmed on Twitter that the high
evolutionary did in fact survive and was
locked up in a prison cell on nowhere
that we see in a deleted scene James
Gunn said it would be quote silly and
Hollow of a rocket to refuse to kill him
only to have him die on the exploding
ship whether we'll see him again as
anyone's guess but given Marvel's
penchant for unexpected returns I'd say
we will there's also a good chance we
might see the new iteration of the
Guardians of the future possibly in the
wrap-up of the Multiverse Saga given how
powerful Kang is and how hard it'll be
to defeat odds are they're going to need
every hand on deck for that and who
knows we've also seen some Clues the
Marvels now we might see a new cosmic
lineup of Heroes called the annihilators
and some of these members of the
Guardians could be part of that or Peter
Quill or mantis we'll see hey thank you
so much for watching this re-breakdown
please support all three channels in the
new rockstars Network you can follow me
on all social media at eavos follow new
rockstars thanks for watching I'll see
you next time bye
[Music]
foreign